there seems to be something wrong with
the way that most of us eat how is it
that we can be both overweight and
constantly hungry how can we eat so much
and still be so tired
proponents of intermittent fasting claim
that they have the answer and that this
diet or protocol can help to assist
weight loss improve health increase
longevity and even boost focus and
willpower but is it all it's cracked up
to be
I initially began intermittent fasting
because I'm the buyer and that's what
I'm supposed to do this is a diet or bio
hack that's become incredibly popular
and so I needed to check it out and see
what all the fuss was about I was also
interested in losing body fat not
because I have any particular interest
in getting slimmer or more ripped but
because you need abs in thumbnails in
order to get two clicks and I was
interested in the idea of auto 4G during
my time with it I found it to be some
more surprising benefits too as well as
some unexpected obstacles and hurdles
and as I've researched more deeply I
found some really interesting theories
and studies relating to auto foggy brain
function hormone balance and more some
of these were very positive and exciting
others suggested I should proceed with
caution it's fair to say that I now view
fasting entirely differently there's so
much to cover here and so many aspects
of our health affected by fasting but I
couldn't possibly cover it all in a
single video in this part 1 then I'll be
discussing fasting for short-term weight
loss and auto 4G in part 2 I'll be
looking at its effects on muscle mass
insulin resistance fat adaptation and
more and finally I'll be providing some
actionable tips and advice to help you
understand how you might use
intermittent fasting in your own diet if
you're really eager though and can't
wait for those subsequent videos you
could always check out the huge and
incredibly comprehensive article a
linked in the description down below
it's over 5,400 words with all the
studies and references linked I'd also
highly recommend to other YouTube
channels SIM lands and the channel
called what I've learned if you're
looking for more information on this
topic both of those are excellent
resources and guys if you're interested
I'd really love to work with you both in
the future
ok so first the basics of intermittent
fasting the basic idea behind
intermittent fasting is that you go
through periods of not eating there are
lots of ways you can break this down but
perhaps the most popular option at the
moment is the 16-8 fats
that means you're fasting for 16 hours
and then eating for eight
that might sound extreme but when you
realize that you'll be spending eight of
those sixteen hours sleeping you realize
that you're really only skipping
breakfast and pushing lunch back a bit
in most cases breakfast is actually
named for the fact that you're literally
breaking your fast you're already in a
fasted state when you wake up and so all
we're doing is pushing that window a
little bit further at its most
simplistic one of the biggest benefits
of intermittent fasting is that it
provides an easy structure for reducing
calories instead of needing to count
every single calorie you can instead
just rely on the fact that you'll be
eating less because you have less time
to do so many advocates of if' rave
about the fact that they can eat
whatever they like during their
eight-hour window and that they can keep
their calories down without the stress
this is indeed beneficial I would stress
the importance of eating healthily
during that time still good nutrition
actually becomes even more important
during this time if you want to ensure
you're getting all the things your body
needs and if you want to build muscle
then you also need to make sure you're
chowing down on lots of protein it's
certainly possible to maintain big
muscle on this diet they that said some
studies do show that fasting can
decrease the amount of lean body mass
when compared with calorie restriction
I'll be coming back to this in part 2
some people find that fasting leads to
better adherence meaning that they find
it easier to stick to their diet and
it's easier to fit around their
lifestyles I personally find that the
social pressure to eat is one of the
biggest challenges when it comes to
dieting seeing as we primarily eat
socially in the evenings fasting during
the first half of the day makes
intuitive sense to me and for me
intermittent fasting has clearly worked
one way or another when it comes to
losing weight I've definitely managed to
improve the appearance of my abs through
the diet and bring out more definition
elsewhere - I can't say whether this is
due to calorie restriction alone made
easier by the simplicity of an eating
window or whether it's the result of
some magical properties of fasting what
I can say though is that fasting has
also made it much easier for me to
control my diet in general it seems to
have simultaneously improved my
willpower and made me less prone to
hunger pangs whereas I would have once
struggled not to snack on the odd thing
during the hours between breakfast and
lunch I can now much more easily forget
about food for long periods or overcome
my insane urge to eat yes
today's leftover carbonara there's been
on the site in the kitchen overnight
what about the science intermittent
fasting certainly can work as a
weight-loss method for many people then
and this has been shown many times but
whilst some people say that if' is
nothing more than an eating strategy
others argue that it actually has
significant benefits when it comes to
weight loss and to their general health
every day what I do is I fast for 16 the
question does intermittent fasting
increase weight loss if calories remain
the same the answer is unfortunately
uncertain owing to insufficient research
many studies focus predominantly on
alternate day fasting rather than
strategies like 16:8 and don't control
for enough variables so how might I F be
more efficient more importantly what
about the other purported benefits of
intermittent fasting what happens to the
body when you fast to answer that
question we first must consider how food
or lack thereof normally impacts on our
body so if you don't eat the first thing
that will happen is that you'll use up
your blood sugar once that's gone you'll
then turn to your glycogen stores in the
muscles and in the liver
these take anywhere between 24 to 48
hours to deplete depending on what
you've been eating prior and your
activity levels so you're not going to
exhaust this resource on the typical
16/8 fast or even on the warrior diet
well this does mean though is that when
you eat subsequently those calories are
first going to be used to replenish
those glycogen stores what it also means
is that you aren't constantly spiking
your blood sugar throughout the day when
you spike blood sugar this corresponds
with a spike in insulin secreted by your
pancreas which in turn can lead to fat
storage so by fasting you're at the very
least avoiding these spikes and troughs
this can help to improve insulin
sensitivity potentially preventing
conditions like diabetes insulin
encourages fat storage and also prevents
the breakdown of fat but insulin is also
responsible for encouraging the storage
of glycogen in the muscles and it's
necessary for us to break down and
absorb nutrients are ushering amino
acids into the cells we need insulin as
anyone with diabetes will tell you
spiking blood sugar also leads to an
increase in serotonin the feel-good
hormone which is due to the tryptophan
content in our food which the body uses
to create serotonin serotonin
subsequently gets converted into
melatonin this
hormone these are also inhibitory
neurotransmitters that reduce brain
activity and heart rate this is why
after eating a big meal you'll feel
great and then collapse onto the couch
before falling asleep
your body's in what is known as a post
prandial state meaning post meal or a
fed state bodybuilders will notice as
being anabolic and of course this is
also when protein synthesis and muscle
building occurs largely thanks to the
activation of the protein mTOR mammalian
target of rapamycin this is released in
response to the heightened presence of
energy and nutrients particularly
protein it leads to increases in
hormones like igf-1 and it makes it
easier for us to put on muscle and fat
so what happens when you stop eating low
blood sugar will conversely trigger a
spike in cortisol levels cortisol being
the stress hormone this is combined with
an increase in noradrenaline raising our
metabolic rate and actually leading to
heightened fat loss in short this is
your body going into the I must find
food mode and it's actually one of the
processes that causes us to wake up in
the morning our sleep/wake cycle is
closely tied to our diet in fact I'll
talk about that more in part two in
short though we're as reducing calories
may decrease your basal metabolic rate
fasting can actually increase it
cortisol also leads to the release of
myostatin the substance that breaks down
muscle tissue cortisol also acts in an
antagonistic manner to testosterone in
short if you have more cortisol then you
will have a less testosterone the link
between cortisol and mood explains why
we get hangry and why fasting has been
observed to increase focus and mental
clarity this is a little like taking a
cold shower in order to trigger a
sympathetic response and increase focus
and it's one of the benefits I've really
enjoyed myself when using fasting at the
same time fasting means that less energy
is spent on your gut I'm reading a book
called sapiens at the moment which
describes how mastering fire and
learning to cook allowed the human
species to shrink our intestines and
thereby use up less energy on digestion
that in turn might have allowed our
bodies to support bigger brains it
stands to reason then that by digesting
less in the mornings you're also leaving
more energy available for other key
processes like thinking as a side note
it's really surprising how much of a
difference not preparing breakfast can
make your productivity
we spend a lot of time cooking eating
and washing up with that gun you'll find
your productivity skyrockets especially
if like me you found yourself using food
as a way to delay productivity at the
same time that all this is going on our
alpha cells in the pancreas secretes an
alternative substance called glucagon in
response to low blood sugar
glucagon in turn encourages the release
of energy from the stored glycogen in
the liver and muscles it's what happens
once that supply of glycogen is depleted
though that's really interesting during
activity we burn a substance called ATP
adenosine triphosphate which increases
levels of a MP adenosine monophosphate
the constituent of ATP that in turn
activates a protein called a MP
activated protein kinase which reduces
protein synthesis through the inhibition
of mTOR in short mTOR and ampk exist at
opposite ends of the spectrum and help
to regulate catabolism and anabolism
respectively for all these reasons then
being in a fasted state is excellent for
encouraging fat loss it ramps up your
metabolism while guaranteeing that you
burn fat and other supplies at 18 to 24
hours insulin levels are at their lowest
ensuring lipolysis aka fat burning but
for the very same reasons many strength
athletes assume that ampk is the enemy
in fact though the mpk has an incredibly
beneficial side effect called auto fuji
auto average is a buzzword that has been
doing the rounds recently since its
discovery one yoshi Noro
asumi the 2016 nobel prize you see the
problem with the chasing after mTOR is
that while it increases protein
synthesis and hypertrophy it also leads
to uncontrolled growth and an increase
in the number of errors and junk
materials this in turn can result in
numerous serious health problems
including cancers tumors physical signs
of aging acne and neuro degeneration all
things known to be on the rise in
general if you are constantly eating
throughout the day your body remains in
a constant frenzy of anabolism or topher
g which translates roughly to self
eating acts as the perfect counter
balance to this essentially Auto FG
describes how cells will recycle their
waste components in short when fasting
the body needs to get its amino acids
and other nutrients from somewhere so it
breaks down things like toxic waste
products damaged organelles
and more particularly beneficial is
might offer G or tropi G of
dysfunctional mitochondria the cellular
energy factories this in turn can reduce
harmful reactive oxygen species that
otherwise cause cell degeneration over
time through all these mechanisms or
topher G has been shown to promote the
lifespan of many species of animal for
this to occur first the junk elements
are transported to a kind of waste bag
in the cell called the OO top of the
dome these are then taken to the cells a
lysosome in order to be broken down for
energy and biomass in short this is
cellular recycling and there's a great
link in the description down below
they'll explain that in more detail so
how long do you have to fast before
experiencing or topher G some reports
suggest that it takes 12 to 16 hours to
experience the full benefits of Auto 4G
others have suggested 24 to 48 hours
a paper called progressive alterations
in lipid and glucose metabolism during
short term fasting in young adult men
suggested that 18 to 24 hours was the
period that saw the greatest drop in
insulin and the greatest increase in
lipolysis the fat breakdown this would
likely coincide with higher levels of
Auto 4G in all likelihood the amount of
time it takes to feel the full benefits
of fasting would vary greatly depending
on individual differences such as
metabolic rate as well as other
variables such as activity levels
certain types of exercise like HIIT are
particularly effective at using glycogen
and the amount of nutrients stored in
the body prior to the fast note that you
can't experience the full benefits of
all topper G by simply cutting out carbs
or through calorie restriction tiny
amounts of leucine alone are enough to
trigger the release of mTOR which also
means you shouldn't use BCAAs when
fasting to try and prevent muscle
breakdown tryptophan is likewise found
in many proteins in short you need to go
totally calorie free in order to enjoy
the full benefits of intermittent
fasting and actually a drive fast would
lead to even greater or Topher G
benefits that's why I personally don't
feel that alternate day fast like 5:2
which permit you to consume a certain
number of calories during your fasted
days make as much sense as going
completely nutrient free for a portion
of the day it's work as a method of
calorie restriction for many people but
that's probably about it well Tata G has
been implicated by some as an
explanation for why people who are
starved for long periods of time don't
experience a large
amounts of excess skin around their
stomachs I was personally very impressed
when I noticed that a skin tag appeared
to shrink after several weeks of fasting
that said we also shouldn't be tempted
to make the very human mistake of
putting everything into neat little
boxes autopsy occurs all the time in our
bodies on a lower level fasting simply
ramps it up to a significant degree so
you can be in varying states of etapa g
this is a spectrum rather than the
binary several other things can also
increase your topper G including
physical exercise resistance training in
particular coffee green tea and
resveratrol it's also a mistake to
ignore the potentially negative side
effects of Lata for G while it can
prevent the onset of cancer and reduce
the progress of cancerous cells in the
early stages it can also actually
support advanced cancerous cells which
use its protective properties to aid
that our own survival
likewise certain diseases also seem to
be able to benefit from our top a G even
turning it against us in order to attack
our healthy cells so we shouldn't paint
intermittent fasting as a magic cure of
any sort rather we should look at it as
potentially a useful tool viewed in the
larger context of health and nutrition
that said fasting for the necessary
amount of time may increase Hilltopper G
by as much as five times bringing many
health benefits as you can see then
intermittent fasting is potentially a
very potent tool for boosting health and
it's certainly a subject that can
benefit from further investigation and
research it's also very useful for
weight loss next time I'll be looking at
this in more detail I'll look at how
intermittent fasting impacts on ketone
bodies gut bacteria insulin resistance
factor adaptation muscle mass and more
so if that sounds good then thanks a ton
for watching and I'll see you next time
bye for now
you